the agenda is said I'm bring cough in
Berlin it's time to talk Iran and the
West a new beginning or a false start
with a big smile the give and take of
forming a new government in Germany who
wants to really share power and Greek
lawmakers arrested as a crackdown on the
far right begins welcome to the show
everyone I've invited three people today
to talk argue and pry apart these
headlines my first guests usually
explains events and politics here in
Germany to his readers back home in
Greece but today he's turning things
around he's helping to explain Greece to
the rest of the world I'm happy to
welcome to the show Theo kuva cassie is
the berlin correspondent with a major
daily paper in greece the it's good to
have you on the show my second guest is
a rising star in German Chancellor
Angela Merkel's CDU party here in
Germany I'm happy to welcome back to the
show benedict puttering he's been here
before and he's going to be our future
government insider today on the show
benedict good to have you back here
today and my next guest is an insider as
much as anyone here in the West can be
when we talk about Iran's diplomatic
calculus I'm happy to welcome to the
show adnan tabatabai he is a respected
analyst on Iran here in Berlin we're
going to open it up with you at none
maybe you can shed some light on what it
was we saw at the United Nations last
week with the President of Iran what was
going on there really well I believe
that for the first time after years or
maybe even decades we have the situation
that we have actors in Iran as well as
in the United States who seem to be
genuinely interested in rapprochement in
setting up some kind of relation
relationship in a quite cautious way but
still I think this is what we are seeing
and this is what we saw in you
work in particular I mean that's a very
as a positive spin on what and what
we're seeing right now let me ask
everybody at the table on are we seeing
the end of the ice age between the west
and Iran with what we saw last week what
do you think Benedict I would say it
seems to be that at least the ice is
melting a little bit because for the
first time since 30 years there was
direct contact between an American
president and president Ronnie I think
that's something it's really special but
we have to to see where it goes what do
you think do good news or should we be
more cautious no I think it's good news
even starting to talk is good news
because we remember when India and
Pakistan tested their their atomic bombs
the nuclear bombs Iran was not even a
topic of conversation in this media now
it is and it's going to come into the
conversation with a little bit more
respect from other yeah and i think
that's that's good for diplomacy that's
good for the plumbers and a lot of
people are saying of course they're
crediting the new president in iran for
that iran's president Hassan rouhani
maybe the unexpected darling in the
diplomatic world right now but his move
toward the west obvious symbolic right
now it made some of his own countrymen
see red hardliners in Tehran threw eggs
and shoes at his car when he returned
from New York and they shouted death to
America never honey may know how to work
a crowd in New York but at home he's
working on his ability to walk very
politically charged tightrope Iranian
president Hassan rouhani has started an
unprecedented charm offensive in a bid
to thaw frosty relations with the West
speaking at the UN last week rouhani
promised he would work with world
leaders to make a ron's controversial
nuclear program more to
his parent he also spoke by phone with
President Barack Obama in the first
diplomatic contact with the u.s. in over
30 years but the Iranian olive branch
has met with mixed reactions back home
rouhani's turned westward has angered
hardliners his supporters hope the
diplomatic overture will help end
international sanctions that have heard
a ron's economy is Rohani genuinely
trying to reset relations with the
international community ednan is what
we're seeing is it rouhani's idea well
in fact I believe it is because if we
consider his political biography and
also the political biography of the
people he has invited into his
government then these people are much
more open to relations with particular
Western countries and also the United
States therefore I believe it is his
idea and the important fact here is that
he at least for the moment seems to have
the important backing of the supreme
leader in his effort to establish some
kind of relationship or contact with the
United States I mean he is he's been
given the authority by the Supreme
Leader to try and change diplomacy right
now um I also i think i remember reading
that he also asked to be in charge of
the nuclear program that the president's
usually not in charge of that and he's
been given that authority so it sounds
like we're looking at a president who
wants to move the country in a different
path but the supreme leader is for now
at least on the same page with him he is
I mean it goes without saying that that
the supreme leader is the one person
with the final decision on important
policy issues such as the nuclear
dossier and the fact that he was that
rouhani was able to transfer this
dossier out of the supreme national
security council into the Foreign Office
is a one important step I would say and
shows that he is making
that this dossier is now a policy field
of the Foreign Office and no longer a
national security issue where you have
taboos on talking about it and a highest
possible confidential situation on it
and this move was approved by the
supreme leader which i believe is of
upmost importance are we seeing the
strongest iranian president that we've
seen in at least 15 years 20 years
arguably so yes because with the help of
actors like hashemi rafsanjani and also
mohammad khatami rouhani got popular god
has got a popular basis and at the same
time enjoys trust and full authority
towards the elites of the regime and
this combination is quite unprecedented
outside is is the responsibility now
that people are saying is with the west
in other words to add to react now to
iran is that an accurate analysis of
where we are right now has ruhani thrown
the ball to the west I think it's now
time for a kind of a double strategy you
know on one hand we have to follow the
new path of diplomacy and and talks as
Obama is doing but on the other hand we
cannot be naive so we have to go on with
checking what are they doing is it not
only a smart move to gain time for their
nuclear program because I think we have
to be everything but not even in this
question because the whole region is in
a very difficult situation right now so
for also for the Iranians it would make
sense to just to to make a smart move to
gain some time to to lower a little bit
the risk of an intervention for example
made by the Israelis I'm just wondering
how much substance that really is here
though in this desire to really improve
relations I let me ask you know the
other journalists here at the table Thea
do you think this president has been
schooled on how to be the most media
savvy president they've ever
and that's what's making everybody get
goose bumps when he walks in the room it
could be that his he's following his
lying for quite a long time now many
many years of what I've seen in research
but I think we should consider as a
magic word sanctions sanctions okay Iran
is suffering with the sanctions and I
think one of the main topics to be
discussed would be that and we talked
about success of the sanctions the fact
that we have someone like rouhani in
power saying these things is proof that
the sanctions are working sanctions own
work in one way or another because they
stop the flow of quite important items
okay one way and another but I mean have
we reached that point now where you know
we've broken the back where they they
have to relent on something I mean the
Germans more that I don't think Iran
ease down to its knees no because of the
sanctioned I don't believe that it would
be a lot better for the economy and for
the society if the sanctions were lifted
or lessened but there's a lot going on
there I mean there's a lot going on
inside Iran to visit Lebanon I mean the
demographics obviously have changed a
lot in the last 30 years and the
president I mean rouhani he has to look
around and realize that he has a nation
full of young people they need a reason
to get up in the morning absolutely and
I think certainly sanctions played a
role and but they're just one factor out
of many who have led to this shift in
how to approach Western countries well
ask you know you're the inside here
would you say the sanctions have worked
well it depends on how you would how you
frame it I mean in terms of causing
economic troubles in Iran then certainly
they had they had a major impact leading
Iran to
to the close to an economic collapse no
this was not the case they cannot the
economy is quite stable which does not
mean that it is growing and that is that
there's actually positive developments
going on there but at the same time the
the aspirations of the people and also
the different political strands that
exist inside the country who have always
been pushing for more political openness
you were just there in August right
right oh it's so what's the mood there I
mean if you were to walk up and talk to
you know someone in in a coffee shop or
something what are they going to say
well I'm from what I sensed when i was
there through the many conversations
there is some cautious optimism and this
optimism in my point of view comes out
of some kind of political maturity where
being naive for instance is not an
option the people know that the things
that they demand from rouhani improve
improving the economic situation
improving the situation of civil rights
they are fully aware of the fact that
the president will need a lot of time to
to tackle these issues and to address
these issues but they are quite positive
that these people who are in rohani's
government are the right people to do so
you talk about civil rights and I'm
wondering if there's going if we're
going to get just a lot of window
dressing on this issue from rouhani and
I'll tell you why I'm worried about that
his Twitter account was changed as soon
as his plane left New York and headed
towards Iran you know he had tweeted or
someone in his team had tweeted these
really nice tweets about the the
conversation with President Obama and
about him telling Obama that America is
a great country and all of those things
disappeared as soon as they left the
United States and then of course access
to twitter was stopped that doesn't
speak well for a country that wants to
improve the rights of its people's does
it well first of all I wouldn't really
view Twitter as an important indicator
here I would rather shed light on
but they know the world is looking at
that I mean when he was here where we
when he was in New York talking to the
public everyone was following him on
twitter yet buzz was there I mean
they're they're they're using Twitter as
well as Facebook for what i would say
some kind of cyber public diplomacy but
for people from what you were referring
to like the civil rights there are much
there are different things of much
higher relevance inside the country
releasing political prisoners is one
important factor and of course releasing
prisoners one week before going to New
York has been quite quite a smart move
but we have to consider who was released
and gnashing so today of course alone
would have been a PR coup that would
have been sufficient to amaze the
international community but also there
were high rank reformist politicians
like no sin i means are they released
who are outspoken critics who in my
point of view are politically or let's
say in terms of political openings much
more relevant than for instance nesting
so today who is an international star if
you will so therefore these are actually
the things going on inside the country a
part of other things that indicate that
there might be some improvement in terms
of civil rights okay I mean you feel
good right now about I mean what Germany
feels good about what's happening I
think first of all I think the the
sanctions worked very well because
without the sanctions I think there
would wouldn't be any kind of political
change in Iran right now because then
people like Ahmadinejad would still be I
think pretty strong for us I think for
the international community the most
important thing is the nuclear program
so we want to be sure that they are not
able to to have a nuclear nuclear bomb
that's I think the main also concerning
towards Israel that's the main issue I
mean are we going to get that I mean
what's the timeline for rouhani right
now at not I mean he doesn't have an
eternity to change things around does he
well obviously I mean the point is if we
are I mean you just you just mentioned
the most important thing
in your view is the nuclear issue I
believe the most important thing should
be the well-being of Iran's people
before anything else I mean in terms of
Nash international security obviously
the nuclear issue plays a major role for
for your perspective but what I would in
general expect European countries in
particular Western countries democracies
is having in mind what's best for the
people inside the country and if rouhani
and his government know how to improve
the situation inside the country and it
takes time we should give them all the
time in the world but we're on the
nuclear issue that before we move on if
if he does not have substantive progress
within six months to a year he's going
to disappear isn't he well I I can't
really tell how patient or what what a
window of opportunity is granted to him
by Western countries all I know it's
about what the West is giving I'm
talking about what the Supreme Leader is
giving him the Supreme Leader and the
hardliners they're being they're giving
right now they're saying okay this is
your chance but everything I've read has
said that the timeline is short and
that's my question to you I mean what do
you see a year from now in fact we have
read things on under Spiegel about
possible things rouhani might put on the
table about opening the photo site
reducing enrichment up to a level of 3.5
or even five percent I can't tell
whether these information are accurate
or not but these points are on the table
and mr. Zarif reiterated that in his
interview with ABC and then of course
the other question is sanction it says
we have to represent yeah sanctions are
not just something there are there are
laws and in order to lift them it's not
as easy as we think to lift sanctions
they have to be there as well they lift
lifting sanctions is important there is
very all right we need to move on and
we're going to move now to right here in
Germany you can call it one of the
ironies of political life in this
country the
campaign leading up to the national
election lasted exactly six weeks how
long should it take after the election
to form a new government well as it
looks now Germany may still have it sold
government when 2014 begins no one is
rushing to share power with Chancellor
Angela Merkel and her conservative CDU
but the problem is the CD you did not
win enough votes to govern alone so
here's another irony the winners of the
election need a loser the Social
Democrats and the Social Democrats as
losers have made it clear they are in no
rush German Chancellor Angela Merkel led
her Christian Democrats to a resounding
victory in September's general election
but with her coalition partner of choice
the business-friendly fdp failing to
make it into parliament miracle will
have to reach across the aisle to form a
new government both the greens and the
Social Democrats have said they're open
to coalition talks but not without major
concessions from the Chancellor the SPD
wants to raise taxes on Germany's
highest earners to pay for new public
spending that something Chancellor
Merkel has refused to support will the
Christian Democrats have to break
campaign promises to form a government
that's the big question isn't it
Benedict of course you guys are going to
have to basically you're gonna have to
go back on your word that you made
before the election in order to put a
government together of course it's
always the case after elections if you
come on it didn't win that so it wasn't
that I wasn't the case for years ago
that yeah because there was clear that
we can form a government quite quite a
quick with the Liberals yes so this is
an unusual situation to be in yeah of
course you cannot expect that the result
of an election is always the same so
it's every time it's it's it's a little
bit different so in this this time we
have the the Greens in the parliament
and also the Social Democrats and also
the link but I
we will not have talks with the linkage
the left party so i think it's it's now
time for talks and negotiations are you
surprised at how quickly the euphoria of
the CDU when evaporated actually no
because it was clear already at the the
eve of the elections that we have a
different situation towards building
forming a new government because the
Liberals they are out now but people
were really excited about because it was
a great edu of course because it was a
great victory for the CDU and the union
for the party yeah but the party is one
thing so but of course you're happy as a
party member that you've won and that
you have a great result Angela Merkel is
is stronger than ever but on the other
hand you see will it be difficult to
form a government and that was quite
more or less no one was talking about
that on the legend you know you and I
spoke right on election night and and I
asked you about you know the feelings
after you know finding out that your
party had had you know brought in the
most votes it had seen since unification
of the country I just want to play a
part of that interview let's just go
back in time now and look at the mood
you were in on that night let's play it
I do not exaggerate if I say I had a
kind of goose bumps more or less
everywhere it was really really a great
sign and also that she mentioned to us
because we fought so hard for that for
this victory here but I think all
members of the cdu/csu did did their job
very well and tonight it's time to
celebrate and together with our
Chancellor we are let's say back on
track it's a very good sign to have more
now than forty percent in the elections
I mean these still stand by that the
goose bumps are gone I can say but of
course there was a new Fauria that night
because the party was was quite strong
but today it's more you know everybody
is more a bit sober let's say and we see
that it's tough to find a new guy i
think i think you're being you know i
don't think you wanted a big
brutal with us here about the situation
I think that when people look at the
election they get angry at the CDU they
get angry with the German voters because
they were so close to having the the
majority needed to rule alone no I
disagree because it's like they gave you
no weapon on a node you can't know it's
I disagree it's it's it's a little bit
different because we we see that the
Liberals it was quite really close that
they failed to towards the five percent
and also with the aft so there are two
parties there were checked the way votes
away so that was only the that's created
the situation that it would have been
possible to get the absolute majority
which is because we we didn't get fifty
percent of the votes that's quite
unusual I would say and there there is
no reason to be angry with the German
electoral and German voter because there
is a clear sign and a majority for
foreign government yeah but you can't
put that mean you can't you know you
can't create a government based on what
the the majority you know as you see it
you can't do it because you don't have
any coalition partners you have to bring
the SPD in I mean let's let's ask you
know from outside the country I mean the
Germans are kind of there between a rock
and a hard place right now or how do you
see it via well we have to interpret the
result of the election one way of saying
it is yes Chancellor Merkel triumphed
and their CD you with her the other way
of saying it would be what percentage of
German voters actually voted for the
government the outgoing government then
come and I see that if we do our math we
will see that out of the 62 million take
that take out those who didn't vote so
it's less and we see that we are talking
about a majority the oath in that is
center-right that is center right which
is by no means the majority of the
voters one thing put aside second all
political parties in Germany know that
if you are in a curly
you burned your fingers and you burn
your wings well yeah and that's happened
to the the Social Democrats so that's
what happened to the Social Democrats
that what happened to the Liberals right
especially when Chancellor Merkel said
we are not going to support them this
time we did last time and we saw that we
lost too many votes and that made us too
weak yes she's not a good partner is she
she's a partner she's excellent for her
party but well I know but no no from the
palette or not in her part I think she
is she's an excellent chancellor for
Germany and I think that's the most
important thing but with the Social
Democrats I have to disagree a little
bit because we've seen them a government
and after we had the grand coalition
they they received a little bit more
than two twenty four percent or
something but now they've been in
opposition for four years and it didn't
didn't improve very much they only
gained a few percentages so the argument
that they need to be in opposition to
gain strength again it's it's it's not
but at the end of the day the law is the
law and you have no choice but to take
the Social Democrats to make a coalition
I think at the current moment everything
can happen we will have talks starting
this friday with your Social Democrats
yeah next week we'll have talks with the
greens and also that we do you believe
then at not do you think that we're
going to see you know people like our
friend here Benedict governing with the
greens well and in fact I would go as
step back also and I really believe this
victory is is a very personal victory of
Angela Merkel and less so of the CD us
sees you as a as a party that's just one
take I mean you may challenge this and
this makes of course in these talks now
a bit difficult because it's less
focused on the program and content but
rather on the bit is it isn't the reason
it's it's it's a hollow victory for
Benedict's party isn't the the problem
here is that the CDU and the SPD this is
the Christian Democrats and the search
Democrats they almost look like twins
politically now so there's not a want to
argue over i would i would agree to some
extent with Benedict also about
the fact that the cSPD the Social
Democrats they fail to do their homework
in the past four years therefore as you
say look quite similar on some on some
points and if you now discuss what are
the different issues they need to settle
for a coalition probably they will come
to an agreement and there won't be major
what are we what are we going to have an
agreement on minimum wage I think first
of all you have to say what from the
Social Democrats side I really think
it's not it's not correct and not right
they are only they do not want to enter
a grand coalition because for tactical
reasons of their party what do you want
them what do you want them to give you
you do not want you do not want to raise
taxes I think right the of course of
course we said in our program during the
campaign we don't want to raise taxes
and that is is still our position so we
will enter probably every talk and not
me but but the leaders of our party with
with our program and then you have to to
do afterwards if you you say ok you want
to start negotiations then you have to
work on it on every single issue it's
not about a party and now it's about the
country so then you have to discuss the
issues and if usually sounds like a
campaign all over again no it's not a
campaigner off again right people at the
table have to be serious so if social
democrat or as somebody else you cannot
say i don't want to enter a coalition
because i'm afraid that my party is not
looking good or that we are losing
percentages for the next elections it's
about finding a common position which is
assuring that you have a stable
coalition for the next four years and i
don't see that at the very moment with
the social democrats i think at the
moment they are only thinking about what
is good for their own party as all
parties do what about new elections Thea
people are people now first what people
are now saying that out loud I mean I
have heard people saying that new
elections could my possibility to fix
this problem I don't think that the the
German political environment is mature
enough to go to this kind of a risky
situation where they could call the
Germans back to the post because
that parties cannot form a government
that would bring disgrace to the cover
to the parties and I don't think they
want to do it i don't think i don't
think the social democrats are willing
to risk being blamed for germany not
having it's like it's like I said the
beginning it's give intake and my
question to you Benedict is what is the
CD you willing to give the Social
Democrats to get them to come on board I
I don't think that it's always you know
first we started we will start the tongs
on Friday and then our party leaders
have to discuss if they are willing to
start the negotiations and during the
negotiations you have to find a way to
reach an agreement and I think that's
dinner I I think and that's the most
important thing that you are not doing
these things with the whole German
public because if you want to reach an
agreement it's not about telling
everybody in advance in TV or the radio
what's your red line is and that you are
strict here and there and that you will
not cross it and so on and so on that's
time when the leaders are sitting
together and then trying to find a way
to get this country government we need
we need to move on but I know our
audience its international they aren't
they no angular miracle and a lot know
the finance minister of this country mr.
Shaw I blood if there is a grand
coalition is he going to be able to
remain the finance minister I think it's
not the time to discuss that now because
first it's about the programs and to
find an agreement about the the most
important issues and then about who's
running which ministry and so on and so
on it's not the time now to discuss the
positions because that's really what you
get tell you then we have to move along
hun what does your gut tell you
insurable are going to stay finance
minister or not I think he did a good
job that's all right I'm gonna let you
give us that politicians answer there
Benedict we're going to move on now to
another political crisis but this one is
in Greece the government there is
introducing legislation to make racist
hate speech a crime now it's part of a
crackdown on the Golden Dawn party the
third largest party in the country
now Golden Dawn has surged in popularity
since the beginning of the euro crisis
the party blames foreigners and
immigrants for the country's economic
woes it's rhetoric is aimed at dividing
society and the signs are now there that
Golden Dawn may be behind violence and
even murder over the weekend the Greek
government arrested members of the
far-right Golden Dawn party the
crackdown came days after an alleged
supporter stabbed an anti-fascist rapper
to death the killing struck a nerve in
Greece and focused attention on golden
Dawn's fiercely anti-immigrant rhetoric
and the racist attacks carried out by
its supporters but Golden Dawn still
remains the third strongest party in the
Greek parliament Greece still depends on
bailouts to prop up its fragile economy
and golden Dawn's rise to power has come
in part thanks to popular resentment
over harsh austerity measures imposed by
international creditors with no end to
austerity in sight can Greek democracy
survive the challenge from the right I'd
say very good question theory of what is
your feeling can you can in your country
keep the far-right in check right now
yes I think it can it can keep the far
right in check as far as illegal actions
are concerned not as far as political
actions are concerned if if they go on
talking about how much they love a
national socialism and how much they
adore adult Hitler and stuff like that
okay they might be also become a little
bit ridiculous they've been bugging his
nervous they've been delivered that was
not their main point that's not why they
had sixteen percent in in polls lately
the reason they had sixteen percent in
polls was why was because they started
distributing soup and food to people who
didn't have them only two Greeks only
two Greeks right
Plus aid other type of aids towards them
and they are riding the wave of six
years of austerity six years of
depression economic depression and
psychological depression for many many
many Greeks so people who are depressed
and they're desperate and there one out
of three people is out of work and two
out of three youngsters are out of work
they are willing to listen to whoever
promises a bright honorable future that
was until it was made clear that these
no Nazis are a gang of criminals they
don't hesitate to murder they don't
hesitate to extort selling protection to
night clubs and stuff like that I mean
put it puts the country in the
government is now in a difficult
situation because members of parliament
have been arrested I mean that's the
first time i think i was being the first
time since nineteen seventy-four that
something like that has happened in
Greece yeah so this anti hate speech law
is aimed at a section of the Greek
parliament I mean there's a there's a
lot of you know when Greece image self
problem with over seven years of
dictatorship 1974 it rebuild the
Constitution and things were rather
tense and nobody dared say we are going
to prohibit people from believing that
Nazism is good or whatever mind you the
Communist Party was illegal until then
in Greece so they said no we are not
going to draw any lines and if the
nugget is that they're not trying to get
rid of the party either by banning it
the right now they're not trying to bomb
the part
right there right now they're
discrediting the the party by providing
evidence that from the leadership down
it is a gang of criminals common
criminals who under the pretext of
political activities did criminal stuff
okay that's as simple as that that that
strategy I that's a strategy that you
know that could work if there's no other
legal option right there's no right but
I mean they have to basically starve the
party to with by denying of the Ronnie
fine start financially and in the eyes
of the citizens when they realize okay
we might be a little bit mad with the
government this government the previous
government and the one before that
because they were all corrupt or
incompetent or both now people will not
side by the ones they know they're
murderers they are violators there are
thieves there blackmailers let me ask
you this and we can open it up about
about how the world sees what's
happening in Greece and how the Greeks
see it we've seen so many caricatures of
the German Chancellor Angela Merkel in
the Greek media in the last four years
is the Greek media telling the people
the truth about the causes of the crisis
and about the accountability and where
it should be directed in Greece if you
say media in general i will tell you
there's no such thing in Greece in
Greece you have either the systemic
media the ones who work with this
government the previous government the
one before that and all the government's
the one who were taking receiving
contracts for publicity of public
whatever and so you don't any about
there are two types of media there are
media who say okay we've done a very
lousy job in electing our government and
letting them
work as they want in order to bring too
much debt not any productive investment
that's why the economy is in this kind
of a really bad situation and it's not
going to come out of this bad situation
because they're Germans are going to
give them us give us some more loans but
the Germans are criticized all the time
in the media I mean Benedict let me ask
been anywhere howdy what do you say to
this it is our the Greek people given
the chance to even know the truth about
how much help has been given to them
already in the austerity I think first
of all it's very important that we as
also as Germans are being cautious you
know with giving advice what you know
what to do in greece and in giving
advice to the 22 to the government how
to deal with for example this thing now
what's going on and so on and so on but
on the other end if i see pictures with
angular maker with the Nazi yeah and so
on and so on that makes me a kind of set
because I I think we have the same the
same aim to bring a greased back on
track but on the other hand I also can
understand the people in Greece because
they are suffering really a lot and that
for now more than five years so on I
think the you have to blame the
politicians before the crisis for not
doing their job and the body you say
that well I would be a bit more hesitant
to speak about shared aims and about
that the goals of German politicians or
the EU towards Greece are shared by the
people of Greece or the let's say
politicians in the country I've read on
it I think well I remember the reactions
from France and Germany when they said
we want to put some of the EU decisions
to a referendum what kind of messages
were sent to to Greece from from France
and Germany that was a bit confusing
with regards
the well very basic democratic values
that we have and obviously wherever a
crisis is their extremism flourishes and
I think you made a very good point in
saying that the people did not vote
these Golden Dawn members into
parliament for their for admiring Hitler
but for being there in social socially
problematic environments and in general
it's a major task for every democracy to
deal with radicalism and to deal with
and to draw the line between where can
we can we be tolerant towards radical
elements and currents and what is the
absolute the red line to N and every you
know we have to wrap up here but at the
end of the day the rise of Golden Dawn
it's about the Greek people feeling like
their leaders in Greece let them down
that's a fact leaders of Greece let
people down for the last decades and
it's a fact nobody can deny that one
other thing we have to see is why did
the political system except having
Golden Dawn as an equal part where you
go to this thing about how much
tolerance then you have work too
tolerant and there were two ready to
connect this side of the political
spectrum to the other so-called side end
of the political very briefly yes or no
is it too late with legislation to stop
Golden Dawn in this trend yes not
stopped okay good we can end on a
positive note gentlemen thank you very
much for coming on the show that it's
going to wrap up this edition of agenda
with Brent Gough remember you can
contact me anytime with your thoughts on
the show you can find me on facebook and
on you can tweet me at brent gough TV
and you can email me as well you see the
address on the screen if you want to
watch the show again go to dw's website
or watch us on youtube I'm Brent Goff in
Berlin join me next time when I set the
agenda
I
you